to be part of the black hole it's either
in your blood or it's not it's in my
blood
we have to be sort of intimidating you
can't have any other way in everything
it's like a huge party only that is
silver black we're the most notorious
fans in the league for love us or hate
us
this is absolutely one of my favorite
spots in Santa Cruz I'm still waiting
for that perfect shot I'm skulls being a
Raider fan to me it's a way of life most
of my family cousins uncles are all
Niner fans so I just had to rebel plus
we have more fun on the dark side I
started dressing up in 2001 and it just
slowly progressed I bought these
shoulder pads from a local high school
that was getting rid of them put a bunch
of metal spikes in them and then every
year I just kind of had it on I just
went with the whole pirate theme I got
my inspiration originally from the
violator when I was a kid I used to see
him on TV and tell my dad hey Dad I'm
gonna do that one day and it's kind of
in my blood doesn't make me a better fan
than that guy I just portray it
differently this is my counterbalance
right here this is what relaxes me you
can hear the sounds of the waves
crashing against these rocks down here
the the Bay Breeze it's spectacular so a
little bit opposite on Sunday
Oh
I'm in a Raiders fan since I was a
little girl my name is middle Cindy I am
the lead singer for discordia and we are
a symphonic melodic metal band and rock
star parky that's the name of our 80s
tribute band I started to do the Raiders
gear character in 2009 when I saw Darth
Raider that caught my attention and then
I saw other character superfans or like
oh that looks cool you know so I'm like
alright I'll just give it a shot you
know I like to entertain people the
reason why I came up with the half face
painted look it has to do with the
Spanish culture which is dia de los
Muertos and then the whole outfit
costume I got it from storm which I like
you know the whole comic girl hey look
all I worst metal you know that what
represents me I'm just a regular girl
that works at a doctor's office a
phlebotomist I'm a vampire I'm Charles
Ibarra aka Darth Vader Dark Lord etc etc
I make you a analyst here at Rock u
games it's a social gaming company
Facebook is sort of the platform that we
run on so my job is to test it all Darth
Raider basically the alter ego of what
you're seeing now it's standing up it's
it's chest bumping it's high five and
it's fashion originally there was a guy
that actually personated Darth Vader in
the seventies when Star Wars came out
they moved to LA they came back in 95
and I know it's my opportunity I've
always been a big fan since I was kid of
Star Wars and the guy that dressed up
like Darth Vader so I took it upon
myself to actually
the same character I haven't missed a
game sentence not one game at one
preseason not one regular around fall
it's basically 24/7 Oakland Raiders
inside the Coliseum and that's my
vacation that's my sanctuary that's my
home that's my church
Ganga
game day is just can't even explain how
how would put it is it's just so
exciting I'm a different person with it
on it's absolutely takes on its own
character and gets you amped up and
ready to go relax I dress up for the
love of my team for the tough times from
evader fans oh my god
they say the black hole is really rowdy
and it is I mean even for Raider fans
but to us it's a family black hole I
will never die it's a symbol passion
it's a symbol of the greatness of the
Raiders